هذا نموذج بالحجم الطبيعي
لما
يُعرف بمودة باسم percy ،
إنه موجود على سطح المريخ الآن بعد أن تمكنوا
من إنشائه ، وهنا في المقدمة
يمكنك
رؤيته هنا حيث توجد بعض
الكاميرات حيث نحن  الحصول على هذه
الصور الجديدة التي سنعرضها لك
على الشاشة الآن
لنقول إنهم تمكنوا من التقاط
الصور وهم الآن
بدقة عالية والشيء الآخر
الرائع حقًا هو أن هناك صوتًا
متضمنًا الآن أيضًا  أننا سنحصل على
صوت وفيديو
سيعودان ومن
المحتمل أن يكون الأسبوع المقبل ولكن هذه
الصور الجديدة سترى
ما نراه هناك بطريقة
جديدة وهناك الكثير من التقنيات الجديدة
التي يتم تضمينها هنا  وأنا أعلم أنني
أمشي بعيدًا عن عربتنا الجوالة هناك
ببطء شديد ، ولكن من بين الأشياء الجديدة
الموجودة
هناك طائرة هليكوبتر
ستطير في الفضاء في وقت قصير وما هو
جدير بالملاحظة حقًا حول
هذا الجهاز الصغير هو المرة الأولى
هليكوبتر أنا  يطير على كوكب آخر
ولكن أيضًا الجو على سطح المريخ
رقيق
جدًا ، لذا تحدثت إلى روبرت هوغ ، فهو
نائب مدير المهمة
حول ما يعنيه هذا أن تستلزم تشغيل
هذه
الآلة والاستماع إليها عندما أتحدث
إلى الطلاب أقول
ضربة  وجهك بيدك بخير
ستشعر بـ 1 100 مما تشعر به
هذا هو مقدار
أه الجو الموجود على سطح المريخ ومع ذلك
فقد قمنا ببناء آلة يمكنها الطيران في
هذا الجو
والتحكم في نفسها بشكل
مستقل والتقاط
الصور ثم  الأرض مرة أخرى
وهو أمر مذهل والشيء الآخر
الجدير بالملاحظة
هنا هو المكان الذي سيأخذون فيه
عينات من الأرض هناك على المريخ
ثم يخزنونها بعيدًا في التيتانيوم
الذي سيتم التقاطه لاحقًا
وإعادته إلى الأرض  حتى نتمكن في النهاية من
رؤية ما يعنيه هذا بالنسبة للبشرية
للوصول فعليًا إلى المريخ ومعرفة المزيد
عن
ماهية الكوكب وما إذا
كانت هناك حياة بالفعل
على هذا الكوكب أم لا